Saturn's largest moon.
Titan is unique.
It has its own atmosphere.
Not only that,
it's the only planet or moon other than earth to have bodies of liquid on its
surface.
Would it be possible to take a dip in one of these lakes?
What would the liquid feel like and how far could just whip?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if you could swim in Titan's lakes.
Titan is the second largest moon in our entire solar system.
It's bigger than our moon and even bigger than the planet mercury.
Despite being so large,
Titan has a weak gravitational pull.
Let's say you weigh 70 kilograms here on earth,
on Titan,
you'd wait just 10 unfortunately,
this means you won't be doing any epic cannon balls into Titan's lakes.
If you could find a cliff to jump off,
it would take you quite a while to float down to the surface of the liquid,
but when you finally reached the lake,
you'll plummet to the bottom extremely fast.
The reason you'd have such a hard time keeping your head above the surface is
due to the liquid methane and ethane found in Titan's lakes.
The density of liquid methane is much,
much lower than water,
so you wouldn't be as buoyant.
Swimming on earth is easy because humans aren't as dense as water.
When we're in a swimming pool,
we weigh less than the amount of water that we displace and the force of the
water pushing back on us helps to keep us afloat.
In Titan's lakes,
your body would be much more dense than the liquid methane you're attempting to
swim in.
It would feel as if you were made of stone on the surface of the lake.
The liquid methane would appear completely clear,
but you still wouldn't be able to see two deep due to the dark rock and thick
atmosphere on the moon.
In fact,
Titan only receives 1% of the sunlight we receive here on earth.
I should remind you that you wouldn't even get this far without wearing a
special space suit.
It would have to be strong enough to withstand the temperature of Titan's
surface,
a frosty 178 degrees below zero.
You'd also need it to protect you from the lack of oxygen on the mood,
the deadly levels of nitrogen gas and the gasoline like rains.
Okay,
back to you being underwater or under liquid methane from the bottom of the
lake.
To get back up to the surface,
you'd need to swim up 200 meters.
Once he reached the surface,
you'd quickly realize just how big the lake you're in is.
This is cracking Maray,
which is 400,000 square kilometers for reference.
That's bigger than the Caspian Sea,
the largest lake on earth and bigger than the entire country of Japan.
If you don't like this lake,
you have over 50 other lakes to choose from depending on what kind of view
you're interested in.
Unfortunately,
there's no surfing on these lakes.
You won't find any waves on titan as it's low gravity makes it resistant to
creating them,
so all in all,
not a great day at the beach.
Swimming in these lakes would be pretty tricky and not a lot of fun.
On top of that,
it's not likely that you'll be able to relax on the shore or Suntan.
Maybe it isn't the best vacation spot,
but you certainly can't deny the beautiful view.
Now,
what would happen if you were a space tourist and could travel anywhere you
wanted?
Well,
that sounds like a question for another.
What if.